senators are supposed to be jurors in
the impeachment of a president and we
learned that yesterday 21 Republican
senators 21 over the 53 that's nearly
40% of the Republican senators left the
Senate chamber for long periods of time
while Adam Schiff was arguing the case
of the prosecution during yesterday's
day of Donald Trump's Senate impeachment
trial senators are supposed to be in
their seats during the trial they're
supposed to not miss the proceedings
since this these proceedings are what
they will ultimately be using to decide
are we going to convict or are we going
to acquit the President of the United
States and yet 21 Republican senators
and two Democratic senators were missing
while Adam Schiff was laying out the
case they're not even pretending to take
this seriously and of course we know
they're not taking it seriously we know
they've already decided that they will
be voting to acquit the President of the
United States but they could at least
pretend to take it seriously michael
mcauliffe was a congressional reporter
tweeted about this in the middle of the
day yesterday saying quote just counted
21 empty seats on the Republican side of
the Senate - on the Democratic side a
couple of hours into Adams shifts
presentation some are just stretching
their legs but most are not in the
chamber some of them have been out of
there for a while they're supposed to
decide the fate of Donald Trump based on
the evidence and they are missing the
evidence and we talked on yesterday's
live stream of the proceedings about how
Chief Justice John Roberts who's
presiding over impeachment as the Chief
Justice of the Supreme Court does John
Roberts role is procedural it is not to
evaluate the evidence or render an
opinion part of the procedure that John
Roberts is supposed to be enforcing are
the basic rules like senators must be
there during the proceedings and this
actually may be part of why we only get
two camera angles the entire time c-span
has said they've requested to be allowed
to use their cameras in the Senate and
to control their cameras Mitch McConnell
does not want that and when
you look at the the production of the
stream unless something's changed in the
last few hours there's a shot of the
outside of the Senate which I believe is
still a c-span camera and then there are
two shots we get two camera angles
there's like a zoomed in shot of the
area were shift and Nadler and the
different house managers impeachment
managers stand and then there's a
slightly wider shot that lets you see
the front of the room the tables were
Donald Trump's defense attorneys and the
house impeachment managers and John
Roberts are pictured but no real shots
of the chamber since we would all
immediately realize where the hell are
the senators this is sick and disgusting
and and it is a sham Republicans have
been saying this is a sham they're right
it's a sham but it's a sham because 40%
of them are gone for long portions of
Adams shifts and other presentations in
a sense it's almost as if there are 53
empty seats right because they're all as
far as we know going to vote to acquit
Donald Trump regardless of the evidence
and like I said yesterday on Twitter how
will they decide whether to convict or
acquit Trump if they don't see the
testimony oh that's right they don't
need to it's an absolute and total farce
we're doomed in a sense here and this is
not even really a matter of partisanship
per se it's just childish behavior it's
image who are elected officials it's a
with a lot of them you know we keep
hearing it ever this is boring and it's
it's boring but you are deciding about
whether a president who is only the
third president ever to be impeached is
going to become the first president ever
to actually be convicted on impeachment
and they're bored they're bored and
they're walking around while Adam Schiff
is presenting evidence it's a truly
sorry Bunch and because of the coverage
on Fox News and elsewhere were which I'm
going to talk about momentarily a huge
portion of the country will not even
hear that 40% of Republicans were gone
during much of Adam Schiff speech it
won't even enter their echo chamber at
all ever but it reinforces once again
for better or worse our voice mail today
argues that this is for worse every day
of this reinforces that there's one way
to hold Donald Trump account
I don't even have to say it we all know
what it is and it would be done in
November let me just put it that way
it's nine and a half months away he
won't be convicted on impeachment he's
not gonna be indicted criminally after
he's out of office yesterday I got
questions during our live stream about
how likely do you think it is Trump gets
indicted when he finally leaves office I
don't think it's likely at all I would
not take that bet we have one shot to
force him to suffer a consequence and
it's by voting him out in November let's
now talk about Fox News's coverage
privacy calm is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you $5.00 just for using
their free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman privacy's of service I've been
using for a while now I love it it saves
me a bunch of headaches it's completely
free and it's very quick to set up and
here's how it works when you pay for
something online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number privacy lets you generate
virtual card numbers the payments are
withdrawn from your checking account but
your real card number stays completely
private and you do it all with one click
you can autofill the card number in your
web browser on the phone you can create
12 virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free they
do have a paid version with different
tiers where you can create more virtual
credit card numbers per month cash back
rewards extra security features but go
ahead and sign up for the free service
it's a no brainer companies can't charge
you unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft that costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy calm slash Pakman